hey everyone
we've been quiet for some time since
like the rest of the world
we had some unforeseen hurdles to clear
but the wait is over
let's dive into the open world of dying
light ii
[Music]
the last slice of dying light 2
showcased the mission from the main
storyline
you get after those [ __ ] you saw how
your decisions influenced the narrative
and notably changed the environment
this time we want to give you a broader
look at the game and a sneak peek at
some of the things we'll be talking
about in upcoming months
in dying light 2 you become aidan
caldwell an
outsider trying to unravel a tangled
mystery from his past
its trail leads him to the city probably
the last bastion of mankind in the world
[ __ ]
at first you feel like this intense
brutal place will
tear you apart but then you meet the
night runners
veteran survivors who help people in
better days
by the way i'm a hate gun you were a
night runner
you used to help people remember my
runners are gone
finished a myth
and although it's not entirely clear you
can trust them
you need allies in the dark
and these are the modern dark ages it's
been 15 years since the apocalypse and
the world has changed
the old civilization has fallen but a
new one
has been built on its ashes
people fight desperately for scarce
resources
rules are broken and weakness is
punished
she's innocent three factions struggle
for position in the city
survivors pride themselves on being able
to adapt to any circumstances
and cobble together safe zones almost
everywhere
peacekeepers loyal soldiers who want to
impose their version of law and order
and trample all
in their path renegades ex-prisoners
serving their ruthless colonel
seeking to become sole rulers of the
city
where is
use these factions to reach your goal
help or harm them to reshape the city to
your liking
just remember each faction contains
complex characters
nosey parker ain't you got some kind of
bad habit of yours
so will you follow cold calculation or
your heart the bizarre needs good people
help us and you'll find a home here
some in the city offer no chance for an
alliance bandits outlaws and common
thugs live
only to plunder and kill plunging the
streets into chaos
yet nightfall scares all of them equally
darkness changes the rules of the world
as the light fails the monsters crawl
out of hiding to prey on the poor souls
caught outside the safety of uv rays
hordes of infected pour into the streets
like decaying lava
the deadly spawn of 15 years of mutation
and evolution
your only escape exploit the city's
verticality and flee to the roofs
threat
yet night brings opportunity as well
nests rife with infected during the day
now light empty
[Applause]
to explore them you must tread carefully
but those brave enough to face the
terrors of the night can
loot a jackpot
luckily you have all the tools you need
to survive
your extraordinary parkour skills allow
you to navigate even the most
treacherous terrain
[Applause]
on the roofs you can count on your
parkour acrobatics to save your life
but often you'll have to face your
enemies head on and then you have to be
smart
resourceful
and determined
[Music]
we've worked hard on the essence of our
combat making sure swinging a big
meaty weapon is fun satisfying and well
executed
but even the most brutal fights can be
tactical as well
you have multiple ways to hone your
skills toward the gameplay style that
suits you best
it's up to you if you focus mostly on
mobility and parkour
or aggressive blunt force combat or
a crafty approach where the tools you've
created get the job done
every ability you learn can be a game
changer and possibly a new favorite move
things move fast and quick in dying
light too each moment matters
each move could mean triumph or defeat
choose your actions and friends
carefully everything you do
in the city can reshape the gameplay
environment change the course of the
narrative and decide the fate of the
city's residents
but most importantly you decide your own
fate as well you're about to turn
make sure to stay human
[Music]
you